basta file people e benvenuti non
scusate il mio sono tutti ragazzi in
termini di questo novità perché ultimo
ha detto sta roba
la gente si è presa male tranquilli sono
sempre io sono sull'episodio di fuga e
speriamo di fare le vittorie giuste
allora vediamo di fare le cose giuste e
speriamo che sia la partita finita
all'inizio norma comunque ragazzi sta
roba qua se per me la più semplice se
non che comunque talmente facile che la
gente ti deve rompere le balle e
mettersi in mezzo ogni volta che passa
una porta che parla questo zio come sta
camminando cammina come vuole lui
ok ok perfetto buono proprio lui la
vittoria cioè oggi non so perché i
ragazzi ma nel mio studio fa un caldo
che mi sto sciogliendo però di non
diventare parte integrante del joystick
che sto usando perché potrebbe anche
succedere prove mi ricordo non so quanto
vi farà piacere saperlo che c'era un mio
amico che veniva a casa mia a giocare la
playstation wand ero piccolo piaciuta
talmente tanto dalle mani che aveva
verrà sciolto la plastica del joystick
si vedeva dentro e non sto scherzando
sta roba qua ragazzi credo che sia
quella dove in partenza vado meglio sarà
vi farà strano saperlo ma questa esito
perché si solo il problema è che ieri
eri di e ridicola perché se parti per
ultimo 6 svantaggiato me la morte tipo
full monty
porca vacca però almeno almeno almeno
almeno almeno sei parti per primo se
parto prima rivale in prima fila arrivo
primonumero sicuro quindi dipende però
questa rai quella che in assoluto
preferisco perché anche se gioco coi
piedi la password solo primo c'è un
pomodoro subito dietro il mio culo però
va bene lo abbandona lo stimato perfetto
ragazzi ma che partita ma proprio lui
perché laddove non sia arrivato primo
anche nella prima però scacco iamoci tra
l'altro ragazzi ho visto delle tattiche
in tipton che adesso che le dico anche
se effettivamente ormai un altro
possiamo fine si sono quindi se ne frega
una tattica che io non userò mai mai ma
ve la spiego
praticamente se tu vai sulle piattaforme
sbagliate ok
e che ne so troverò perfetto hai ancora
un millisecondo per salvarti e se ti
tuffi subito ma più parti subito vuol
dire tuffarsi appena la infatti ok
quindi se arriviamo alla fine e manca
una piattaforma sola uno si può tuffare
ci possa dare sopra e tuffarsi subito
appena toccata e anche se una
piattaforma che cade arrivi lo stesso al
traguardo non la faccio perché è
veramente difficile ragazzi però sicuro
è veramente difficile nonostante sia
possibile è molto difficile
la parola stessa mastica chi tanto cielo
rischiava killer pietro killer pietro
2009 se perdo una partita mica ecco
infatti si è suicidato poi c'è killer
pietro davanti che ci si spazza tutta la
strada veniva bene eccola dio
ma veramente statica esiste ragazzi
perché le piattaforme hanno un
microsecondo anche quelle fake che ti
tengono su stufate subito ce la fate
problema è che rischiosissimo vai
speriamo di non fare fall montain anche
se dubito o extra con meno male meno
male che c'è quando c'è secondo io sono
tranquillo l'ho già vinta è ormai
veramente a meno che non succeda quel
bug che passi attraverso le celle o poca
altra roba di netta sfiga mandare di
sfiga piena non teoricamente non la
perdo poi dipende potrei anche fare il
bug c'è il mag il debug ora che ti ho
voluti a piattaforma ma non lo voglia di
farlo perché mica go addosso io te lo
faccio killer pietro sottolinea killer
pietro non ha capito come si gioca sul
gioco fa niente arco demonio non ci sono
arrivato dai killer pietro toni tutte le
piattaforme di sotto bravo miu miu
ricascato fernando ma posso questa cosa
e madonna su cascati tutti trasferiti
solo unico una piattaforma più solo
alcune piattaforme attenzione se la
gestisce
se la porta se la fa seguire non vuol
dire niente stati tagliati meraviglioso
meraviglioso meraviglioso ragazzo
all'unico solo rigo sopra quindi
tranquillo tranquillo se me la tengo tra
ampio vinto affetto c'è una piattaforma
viola ancora no è caduto adesso perfetto
con i viola
raga dovrei avercela fatta e perché
veramente banca a meno che questo qua
non duri un'ora avessi che la
piattaforma già lab e laghi io sto zitto
no ragazzo la per nomi in caso veramente
fatto una figata di a livelli mostrò
dove el'altro quanto quanto ancora c'è
la piattaforma di sopra orco demonio
dove dove sei
ma dov'è è un cheater bona noi non ho
capito dove l'altro ragazzi non lo
vedono c'e non esiste
stavo cadendo pure nono manuela medico
questo
quando da cannes da cani da kari sto
giocando flexammon eccolo è sotto ok è
caduto giù perché li tolgo tutto perché
non c'è niente questo va beh non cade
non cade non cade è caduto la volta o
tutta la strada camminava
sull'invisibile lui perché lui può papa
angula socio giocata malissimo ma male
male forte però vabbè lasciamo perdere
mi avete visto ne va bene allora questa
seconda partita fatta 29 quali file
ti prego uno slang live ti prego uno
slang climb dai tag perfetto ragazzi e
boe e tutto calmo qua parte il mortal
lilly che mi sta venendo addosso non ho
capito niente di quello che è successo
io ho [ __ ] una coda dopo che uno me
la fortuna non ho capito come è volato
143 aiuto con una roma più madonna
che ansia che devo avere ogni volta che
gioca che ansia meno ma non ci sono
stati che non onora la prima la prima
che mai potuto ancora non l'ho capito
due ex con su due ottimo
siamo come prima vabbè se siamo come
prima ragazzi latte il tentativo di
farla meglio di come l'ho fatta prima
perché abbiamo fatto veramente ridere
cioè non sono affatto a vincere questi
sono anche molti di meno degli altri non
ha rischiamo ci aiutiamo itc il a posto
via via via togliatti via tutto il parto
ti prego non devi correre tua madre
veramente brutto perché correte perché
correte il suo gioco non si corre
ragazzi madonna io veramente non posso
vasta vita non si corre in hexagon
smettetela
mio dio non ci arrivo limitare ci provo
bene bene bene
madonna che provata perchè lo stop detto
che è provata una sega anche prima ho
detto strano ragazzi basta smetto di
commentarli a favore mio in essa
cosmetiche non posso fare se non esiste
maledizione veramente ha fatto un salto
km ha fatto ma come ha fatto a fare quel
salto libor col demonio penso di
essermelo fatto questo qua ho detto
fumato me non fu perché mi siete
capitati in sta partita ma è più sudata
riguardi prima è comunque io pensavo di
fare almeno meglio noto peggio ma
edizione veramente tutto niente arrivo
nell'ultima raga per forza almeno c'è un
bel po di terreno però siamo in tre
siamo in stretto tanto tali adesso
perfetto non devi correre madonna guarda
12 guardiola nata non ragazzi non
saranno se la merita non salame correva
correva al madonna se stai correndo poi
avendo ha causato distacco tutta la plec
delle playstation che ci sarà anche la 2
a 1
io entro in casa sua.il dimetto call of
duty metto anche io colpi di roma
io veramente io veramente mi fanno
salire una rogna
te lo meriti fai schifo non si gioca
così ha detto devi saltare sulle celle
esaltare ho giocato due partite piazza
con secondo me bruttissime potevo farle
molto molto meglio per come gioco ex
alone parola vinte tutte e due viti a
posto lasciato momento è un mi piace
iscritte che ad essere iscritti perché
molto importante per supportarli e noi
come sempre ci vediamo a un prestito e
ragazzi
[Musica]